after more than three decades in the
movie industry three-time Oscar winner
Daniel day-lewis has decided to hang up
his hat so Daniel I'm finished the actor
announced that his 2017 film with writer
director Paul Thomas Anderson a 50 set
dress designer drama called phantom
threat will be the last installment in
his esteemed filmography the statement
given via his spokeswoman read he is
immensely grateful to all of his
collaborators and audiences over the
many years this is a private decision
and neither he nor his representatives
will make any further comment on this
subject the notoriously private thespian
may not be willing to elaborate publicly
but he has plenty of reasons to leave
Hollywood's bright lights behind the
toll of being a method actor it's no
secret that Daniel day-lewis takes a
very unique approach to his craft not
only is he exceedingly choosy about
which roles we'll accept but he's also
known to disappear into them throughout
the production process I follow my
curiosity and it takes me into all kinds
of strange places he stayed in a
wheelchair and was spoon-fed by crew
members to fully experience having
cerebral palsy for his oscar-winning
turn in my left foot he spent six months
in the wild to prepare for his role in
the last of the Mohicans he isolated
himself from the cast and crew during
the production of The Ballad of Jack and
Rose he tattooed his hands and trained
for 18 months as a fighter for the boxer
the results speak for themselves that
all that dramatic heavy lifting takes a
toll
well posit my job is to be Dre and I
wore myself up post production
depression not only is the work itself
grueling but once he's done with the
role he has to deal with the emotional
repercussions of letting it go
as he told The Telegraph there's a
terrible sadness the last day of
shooting is surreal your mind your body
your spirit are not prepared to accept
that this experience is coming to an end
you've devoted so much of your time to
unleashing in an unconscious way some
sort of spiritual turmoil he also has
trouble letting go of his characters as
a result and not quite sure what to do
with yourself when it's finished very
hard to conceive and consoles life after
it
cause there is one way see for example
after finishing Gangs of New York
day-lewis admitted to speaking with his
butchered dialect for months after the
film's completion and felt a sense of
alienation during the film's debut
selling rolling stone I got nervous
before the premiere
I knew I'd also feel a sense of sadness
now I have to accept that the film is
complete and no longer has anything to
do with me
secondary career paths he was showered
with decades of praise for his work in
front of the camera but day-lewis
ultimately sought a different level of
fulfillment in his side career as a
cobbler after shooting the boxer he
started a family with his wife Rebecca
Miller and apprenticed in Italy with
master shoemaker Stefano BEMER he told
Rolling Stone it's an antidote to this
other thing I do most particularly
perhaps because you see this visible
evidence you have this tangible thing at
the end and if you up you can see it
very clearly and do it again it's not a
matter of opinion it's either good or
it's bad making shoes might seem like a
strange passion for an Oscar winner but
as we've seen countless times it can be
hard for a celebrity to stay grounded in
the spotlight working with one's hands
to produce work you can point to at the
end of the day seems like a great way to
stay centered allergic to fame even at
the peak of his career day-lewis
retreated from the public eye for years
between projects to spend time on his
family farm in Ireland where he's often
spotted visiting the pub to have a pint
alone unlike a number of his more
outgoing colleagues he's rejected the
notion that he's a public figure at all
times he told the BBC I am whether I
like it or not
a public figure during certain periods
then I disappear it seems of course in
my experience I don't disappear I'm just
doing other things
what I'm doing is reengagement given its
merit as an actor any movie starring
day-lewis earned special attention which
undermines his interests in making
movies in the first place as he told The
Telegraph the work itself is never
anything but pure pleasure but there's
an awful lot of peripheral stuff that I
find it hard to be surrounded by I like
things to be Swift because the energy
you have is concentrated it can be
fleeting the great machinery of film can
work against that
in today's Hollywood that machinery
seems larger and louder than ever and
it's left less room for the quieter
sorts of character studies that
day-lewis tends to favor instead studios
are looking for properties with proven
brand value which means lots of sequels
reboots remakes and cinematic universes
to an actor who built his career on
taking emotional and physical risks it
may no longer be worth working within
those constraints oh oh oh in that case
going out on top when day-lewis won the
Best Actor Oscar for Lincoln in 2012 he
made a cannon II award history by
becoming the only actor to win three
trophies in that category
once you've set such a high bar for
yourself there's really nowhere else to
go but down and day-lewis seems to know
that his status is a legend is well
worth protecting I have a competition I
want no one else to succeed and while
this time seems like the real deal
Daniel day-lewis has walked away from
acting before more than once exact he
left a stage production of Hamlet in the
middle of a show because he thought he
was interacting with the ghost of his
dead father he took five years off after
the boxer and planned a five-year
sabbatical from acting after Lincoln he
told the Guardian I just wanted some
time away from it all I need that quite
often I have quite a strong feeling
about when I should work and when I
shouldn't evidently day-lewis is still
going with his gut and walking away from
the spotlight at last thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]